unos investigadores sospechan que la
miopía es cada vez más común un estudio
del año 2000 mostró 132 casos de miopía
en 400 personas seleccionadas
aleatoriamente un estudio separado del
2015 mostró 228 casos de miopía en 600
personas seleccionadas aleatoriamente y
lo que haremos en este vídeo será hacer
una prueba de hipótesis para ver si
tenemos suficiente evidencia para
sugerir la sospecha de los
investigadores de que la miopía es cada
vez más común si en cualquier momento te
sientes inspirado te animo a que pausa
el vídeo e intentes trabajar el problema
por tu cuenta
ahora vamos a trabajarlo juntos lo
primero que haremos será definir
nuestras hipótesis la nula y la
alternativa
la hipótesis nula no es nada novedosa es
lo contrario a lo que sospechan los
investigadores es decir que la miopía no
es cada vez más común
ahora la forma en la que podemos medir
que es cada vez más común podría ser al
tomar la proporción de personas que
tenían miopía en el año 2015 y
compararla con la proporción de personas
que tenían miopía en el año 2000
así que nuestra hipótesis nula es que no
hay diferencia entre estas dos
proporciones es decir que la proporción
verdadera de personas que tienen novia
en el año 2015 es igual a la proporción
verdadera de personas que tuvieron
noviembre en el año 2000 mientras que
nuestra hipótesis alternativa es lo que
ellos sospechan que la miopía es cada
vez más común por lo tanto estas serían
las situaciones en donde la proporción
verdadera de personas que tienen la
playa en el año 2015 es mayor que la
proporción verdadera de personas que
tuvieran miopía en el año 2000 en este
caso la miopía estaría siendo cada vez
más común porque el 2015
pasó después que el 2000
antes de seguir con la prueba de nuestra
hipótesis nula para saber si la
rechazamos o no y con esto ver si
sugerimos la alternativa tenemos que
revisar las condiciones para la
inferencia esto ya lo hemos hecho varias
veces la primera es la condición de
aleatoriedad y parece que se satisfacen
porque en ambas muestras tenemos
personas seleccionadas aleatoriamente
por lo tanto se satisface la segunda es
la condición de normalidad la cual nos
dice que necesitamos tener al menos 10
éxitos y 10 fracasos para cada una de
las muestras lo cual es completamente
cierto
puedes verlo aquí no que sea un éxito
tener miopía sino que en la forma en la
que construimos este problema podemos
llamar éxito al tener un paciente con
miopía y 400 menos 132 son los fracasos
que también son mayores que 10 y lo
mismo para la muestra del 2015
y por último tenemos la condición de
independencia hay dos maneras para que
se satisfagan esta condición o estás
mostrando por reemplazo o tienes
confianza en que el tamaño de la muestra
es menor que el 10% de la población
parece que estamos en lo correcto al
decir que incluso con esta muestra de
600 personas hay más de 6 mil personas
en el mundo por lo tanto creo que es
razonable pensar que se satisface la
condición de independencia ahora lo
siguiente que debes de hacer en una
prueba de hipótesis es establecer un
nivel de significancia es decir alfa y
en esta ocasión me tomaré a un nivel de
significancia de 0.05 ahora vamos a
suponer la hipótesis nula
vamos a decir que es verdadera y pensar
en cuál es la probabilidad de obtener
una diferencia entre las proporciones
del año 2015 y del año 2000 que sea al
menos igual de grande que la que tenemos
la probabilidad es menor que nuestro
nivel de significancia entonces
rechazaríamos la hipótesis nula y
sugeriríamos la alternativa si esa
probabilidad es mayor que nuestro nivel
de significancia entonces no podemos
rechazar la hipótesis nula y por lo
tanto no tenemos evidencia en favor de
la sospecha de los investigadores
así que continuemos lo que queremos
hacer es encontrar un valor z o un
puntaje z por lo tanto nuestra zeta será
igual a la proporción muestral en el año
2015 menos la proporción muestral en el
año 2000
todo eso dividido entre la desviación
estándar de la distribución muestral de
las diferencias de las proporciones
muestrales entre el año 2015
y el año 2000 ahora esta seta será una
aproximación ya que podemos calcular el
numerador de manera exacta sin embargo
el denominador lo vamos a estimar el
numerador será el año 2015 en el año
228 casos de 600 mientras que en el año
2000 teníamos 132 casos de 400 y todo
esto entre la raíz cuadrada y lo que
usaremos en el denominador dentro del
radical será la proporción combinada no
voy a escribir como p sombrero sub
índice y la razón del por qué usamos la
proporción combinada y esto lo hemos
mencionado en vídeos anteriores es que
cuando hacemos una prueba de hipótesis
suponemos que la hipótesis nula es
verdadera y si la hipótesis nula es
verdadera entonces no hay diferencia
entre las proporciones del 2015 y del
2000 así que para obtener una mejor
estimación de la proporción verdadera
podemos simplemente sumar nuestras
muestras así que el tamaño de la muestra
serán 600 + 400 y el número de casos de
miopía serán 228 132 lo que nos da 360
entre 1000 0.36
y podemos usar eso en la expresión
cuando intentamos estimar nuestra
desviación estándar con esto el radical
será bueno 0.36 que multiplican a 1 -
0.36 lo cual es 0.64 entre el tamaño de
la muestra en el 2015 que es de 600 mas
0.36 que multiplican a 1 - 0.36 que es
0.64 entre el tamaño de la muestra en el
2000 que es de 400 y ahora antes de
sacar la calculadora creo que puedo
simplificar esto un poco porque 228 en
36 de esos 38 y 600 en 36 es 100
entonces esto me darán 0.38 y 132 entre
4 es igual a 33 entre 100 que es 0.33
por lo tanto nuestro numerador va a ser
de 0.05 ahora si ya puedo traer mi
calculadora y poner esto que estoy
escribiendo
lo cual me va a dar aproximadamente
igual
0.05 entre la raíz cuadrada de 0.36
puntos 0.64 esto entre 600 + 0.36 x 0.64
entre 400 y esto va a ser
aproximadamente igual a
bueno me dan un 1.61 déjame escribirlo
aproximadamente igual a 1.61 entonces
una forma de pensar acerca de esto es
que la diferencia que obtuvimos entre
las proporciones muestrales del año 2015
y del año 2000 de 0.05 esta a 1.61
desviaciones estándar por arriba de la
media de nuestra distribución muestral
si suponemos que la hipótesis nula es
verdadera ya partir de esto podemos
calcular nuestro valor p recuerda
nuestro valor p va a ser igual a la
probabilidad de que nuestro puntaje z
sea mayor o igual a 1.61 una forma de
pensar en esto de manera visual es que
si observamos nuestra distribución
muestral en realidad podríamos fijarnos
en cualquier distribución normal ya que
normalizamos para z estamos viendo un
punto que están a 1.61 desviaciones
estándar por encima de la media por lo
tanto z es igual a 1
61 de modo que estamos pensando en esta
área de aquí la cual sería nuestro valor
p y para ayudarnos vamos a sacar nuestra
tabla zeta y vemos que esta tabla zeta
nos da el área acumulada hasta un cierto
puntaje etcétera por lo tanto lo que sea
que obtengamos tendremos que tomar la
resta de 1 menos ese valor
si nos fijamos en 1.61 obtenemos 0.9 mil
463 así que serían uno menos 0.9 mil 463
lo cual es 0.0 537 y observa que este
valor p es ligeramente mayor que nuestro
nivel de significancia esta es la razón
del por qué fijamos nuestro nivel de
significancia antes de todo el
procedimiento no queremos caer en la
tentación de decir ok estoy tan cerca
déjame subir mi nivel de significancia
un poquito para que pueda rechazar mi
hipótesis nula y así tener algo que
contarles a mis amigos no eso no sería
buena ciencia y eso no sería buena
estadística
necesitamos ser disciplinados por lo
tanto dado que nuestro valor pm es mayor
que nuestro nivel de significancia
aunque varía por una cantidad muy
pequeña podemos concluir que
no podemos rechazar la hipótesis nula
y otra forma de pensar en esto dado el
contexto de la pregunta es que podemos
decir que no hay suficiente evidencia
para sugerir que la miopía es cada vez
más común
y hemos terminado nos vemos pronto